bonsoir monsieur bonsoir
laurent baffie francine distel des
pommes des poires l escaut vidéo ville
où partout voilà
bien alors le jeudi 22 juillet dernier
au petit matin sacha distel
s'éteignait francine dans votre
propriété familiale durée yole canada
elles et ils laissés inachevés un livre
sur sa vie qu'il avait commencé un an et
demi plus tôt en compagnie de l'écrivain
bruno tessarech et derrière le dernier
chapitre est resté sous forme de
synopsis alors c'est un livre important
pour sacha distel parce que pour lui ça
a constitué un des éléments de son
changement d'image
et oui c'est ce qu'il voulait laisser en
tous les cas sans savoir que ils
laisseraient aussi vite c'est un peu
comme son dernier cd dont il était venu
parler ici d'ailleurs qui s'appelait
envers et contre vous tiens il voulait
absolument montrer qu'il n'était pas
seulement le le créateur de chansons
rigolotes mais aussi un grand musicien
et un grand crooner un grand musicien
qui a écrit de très belles chansons qui
leur est souvent la face b oui mais
comme c'était la face à qui avaient du
succès forcément elles n'ont pas été
voir longtemps connu que les autres sur
livre qui lui tenait à coeur énormément
à coeur et c'est pour ça que vous êtes
là ce soir pour pour en parler à sa
place lui et l'asse c'est moi qui suis
en première ligne mais non et
je le fais et je fais par amour pour sa
charge parce que ce livre est très
important pour lui il fallait que je
vienne le présenter donc vous allez nous
le lien voilà n'en sommes pas là pour
l'asie c'est difficile pour vous de
devenir paraître ce livre la télévision
on vous a jamais vu en fait vous non
c'est au contraire ça me fait plaisir
bien on est heureux que vous soyez là en
tous les cas merci moi aussi voilà alors
toute façon vous vous croyez à la vie
après la mort donc vous pensez que sacha
ma vie après la vie oui c'est plus gai
ouais penser que sacha distel va vous
aider ce soir complètement ouais
alors dans ce bouquin sacha raconte sa
vie ses parents son père émigré russe
propriétaire d'un magasin de luminaires
à clignancourt bon danseur son père un
séducteur né un peu comme un peu comme
sacha et puis sa mère famille juive
bourgeoise ils sont donc le fameux
raymond ventura ray ventura le créateur
de l' orchestre des collégiens qui sera
à l'origine de la passion de sacha pour
la musique c'est lui qui lui a vraiment
donné le virus absolument et en tout
petit laid il était passionné aurait là
on est à des des concerts et sasha unef
coup de foudre alors sacha raconte la
guerre sa mère arrêtée par la gestapo
les retrouvailles et en 1947 ray ventura
lui demande d'être le réveil matin d'un
artiste qui s'appelle henri salvador
pour s'occuper de lui sur le tournage
d'un film et henri salvador lui fait
découvrir frank sinatra et dizzy
gillespie toujours pour le compte de son
oncle sacha part aux usa en 1952 et à
l'âge de 19 ans il découvre stan getz
miles davis charlie parker enfin c'est
une révélation complète pour lui
complète d oui c'est il a en fait
commencé comme musicien de jazz voilà
ensuite il devient directeur artistique
disque versailles chez son oncle ray
ventura et il devient le meilleur
guitariste français pendant sept ans de
suite oui c'est vrai c'est des trucs que
les gens savent pas comment tout ça se
passait avant moi oui je suis quand même
au courant pour
alors là on entre dans l'éducation
sentimentale de sacha distel ça se
passait avant vous aussi vous êtes un
peu plus au courant
pas tellement j'ai découvert beaucoup de
choses ce livre
qui veut dire quand même c'est que sacha
était incroyablement beau tout est
magnifique guigou vraiment il était
charmant
le charme c'est encore oui c'est encore
autre chose alors la première ça a été
juliette gréco c'est a duré plus de deux
ans et là on découvre tout de suite
quelque chose qui sera récurrent dans
les grandes histoires d'amour de de
sacha distel c'est qu'il était un peu
dominé par l je pense enfin en lisant
lit j'ai découvert qu'elle était un peu
une initiatrice ouais mais elle le
dominer parce qu elle n'encourageait pas
à chanter par exemple les équipements
par qui chantait faux sûrement par way
peut-être qu'elle voulait pas perdre
l'accompagnateur donc les notes c'est ça
alors jusqu'au jour où elle part avec le
producteur hollywoodien d'arriver à
nuque
c'est terrible la scène dans le bouquin
c'est à dire qu elle lui demande de lui
apporter son son passeport à la gare et
quand ils arrivent dans le compartiment
du du vallon lit il trouve gréco avec
des riffs de luxe et pour dire oui
détail amusant il découvre à monsieur
moustachu et juliette un peu trop près
de la moustache et j'ai très malheureux
très très très mal à aures que sacha est
un sentimental grand sentimental on le
voit pas ce que ça recommence encore
avec jeanne moreau il ya en parlant de
jeanne moreau et 10 et une tornade
amoureuse alors je sais pas ce que ça
signifie matadi a une idée comme way
tornade amoureusement toujours pareil
lui il est un peu complexés par l c'est
un peu le le petit jeune qui accompagne
la vedette porte-bagages voilà un petit
peu voilà jusqu'au jour où elle se casse
avec louis malle à d'où le nom d'où le
voilà ça c'est la deuxième donc ces
jeunes moreau et la troisième c'est
brigitte bardot alors brigitte elle
voulait faire des enfants avec les
voulait faire sa vie avec lui ah oui oui
et être être intéressé serbe a été très
accroché moi j'ai d'abord 13 accroché
lui aussi et puis chacun dans leur
métier c'est ça faisait un petit peu
c'est par ouais bah lui il a toujours
cette image avec elle du dugas arriviste
un peu gigolo quand même un ânon battant
dénoncer cet accord attendez il cite un
papier du canard enchaîné qui est grave
mais ça c'est la parole de vérité le
canard enchaîné on sait bien dans le
caennais ont dit le petit jeune homme
qui essaie de se faire un nom à la sueur
de ce qu'on ne saurait trop nommé oui ça
lui a fait plaisir
jusqu'au jour elle le quitte oui
finalement il s'était pour jacques
charrier plusieurs fois
c'est fait il s'était planté à chaque
fois qu elle dit ouais il le dit dire
que nous on imaginer sacha distel comme
un mec super séducteur et tout c'est
vrai qu'il a un défi formidable mais à
chaque fois il est dominé est planté oui
il était peut-être tombé lui penser à
des choses peut-être plus sérieuse mais
ces dames n'ont ouais c'était lui le
sentimental voilà alors il parle pas de
la même strate berg et pousse vadim
comment ça se fait non c'est dommage
parce que c'était une des plus
charmantes elle est venue ici à votre
place elle nous a raconté son aventure
avec sacha
en tous les cas ces trois aventures le
guérissent des stars parce qu'il dit
elle même qu'elle
disons qu'il présentait un peu vrai
voilà il préfère quelqu'un peut-être
deux - il est magnifique voilà un et en
61 il tombe sur vous vous êtes au
courant là oui complètement complètement
alors sur vous vous n'avez rien à voir
cette fille de banquier les gens
viennent de signer entre vrai que ça
change quoi c'était plutôt la championne
de ski que la fille de manquer voilà qu
à l époque la section c'est un coup de
foudre c'est typique parent c'est vrai
coup de foudre il dit dès le premier
soir j'ai pensé qu'elle serait la mère
de mes enfants et qu'on aura un compte
commun il a rajouté
comment ça s'est passé la première fois
ça a été un coup de foudre ouais
j'étais c'était à megève dans un
restaurant de téléphérique côté d'une
curieuse
il faut préciser comment ça s'est passé
j'étais en train de manger un petit
morceau a plus d'essence
et sasha est rentré dans le dans ce
restaurant et il bavardait avec brosses
de trois personnes qui étaient là et
tout d'un coup il s'est tourné vers moi
et il a eu cette phrase d'une banalité
incroyable je crois que nous sommes déjà
rencontrés pas terrible ouais c'est pas
terrible c'était ça marche ça marche 43
ans 43 ans et deux enfants alors votre
secret c'est quoi si vous n'êtes jamais
mêlé de sa vie professionnelle c'est
pour ça que ça a duré aussi longtemps au
je pense pas que ce soit la raison non
non non ça ça a peut-être aidé non non
vous aussi vous avez suivi grand femmes
indépendant vous avez organisé votre
votre vie de votre côté oui c'est à dire
que je vais j'ai une certaine
personnalité dirons-nous je suis une
sportive il ya des tas chose que j'avais
envie de faire et j'ai continué à faire
je vais faire des trucs en himalaya je
suis allé me balader dans certains pays
avec mes copines bon ça charal est un
petit peu à cause de mes absences mais
finalement il en était très fier que g77
autonomie et 7 s'est rien passé dans les
médias comme aux autres parce que moi le
cahier ti non ma première femme m'a
quitté après un trekking dans l'himalaya
allemand un tracking
ça fini c'est pareil mais c'est pas de
salle odéon
et vous non non non j'aime bien les
népalais mais sont pas terribles
sérieusement bon ben vous le savez il
vous trompez de temps en temps vous
saviez à l'époque non bien sûr je savais
ouais et vous réagissiez comment je
disais rien ou les cieux passer l'oral
je laissé passer l'orage c'est que j'ai
des parents qui ont divorcé quand
j'avais 17 ans j'étais ravi qui divorce
parce qu'il n'arrêtait pas de se
bagarrer et c'était affreux et je
voulais vraiment réussir ma vie de
famille bon je suis tombé sur un homme
absolument charmant très agréable à
vivre nous avions deux enfants et c'est
pas comme dans les films américains où
il ya une tromperie on casse tout
investir non sans souffrir quand même
sur dix souffrent r oui vous avez bien
sûr bien sûr mais je m'en suis remise
parce que finalement au bout du compte
ça quand même été une réussite ouais qui
sait le danger quand épouse un playboy
aussi c'était un playboy oui c'est ce
qu'on m'a dit non playboy est pas le bon
terme beau gosse charmant beau gosse
charme est un tout un talentueux
non c'était pas et que tu as n'ont pas
dit non on reste un beau gosse alors on
oublie que tu arrondi
jaarbeurs par contre les filles à wil
énormément de succès bien sûr quand vous
mettez un gourmand 1 devant devant une
boulangerie il ya plein de bons gâteaux
il ya un moment donné je suis diabétique
mode
à droite et en 1985 ça tourne au drame
c'est la fameuse affaire chantal nobel
alors dans ce livre c'est la première
fois que sacha distel s'exprime sur
cette affaire et ce qui est terrible
c'est qu'il dit qu'il éprouve toujours
une grande impossibilité en parler
vingt ans après oui mais ça a été très
très très dur une période de
de sa vie très très très dur parce qu'il
ya une une certaine presse qui l'a
entièrement démolie alors qu'il n'y
était pas pour grand-chose bons sont les
choses de la vie ça
dit dans le bouquin qui se rappellent
plus de l'enchaînement des faits
non mais j'ai des amis qui ont eu des
accidents et effectivement quand il ya
une perte de connaissance on oublie ce
qui s'est passé exactement avant et
pendant il avait perdu la mémoire de ce
qui s'était passé sur cette route ce
soir là oui absolument ce qui dit à un
moment d'en laisser griser je regarde
chantal nobel les deux chiens la porsche
le virage et je me retrouvais l'ailé là
allongé mais c'est bien après
oui mais je pense que je fais moi
j'étais pas là mais je pense que c'est
comme ça que ça s'est passé alors pour
vous qui prenez les choses avec une
certaine
sagesse visons la school has a dû être
dur quand même non
oui sa part été très facile pas été très
facile
g
mais
c'est à ce moment là que toute la
famille se soude oui et moi en premier
vous l'avez paul et à oui complètement
là on est passé à travers et les gars
ont été formidables aussi et puis mais
ça a duré longtemps quand même
nous on nous a pas ménagé dans cette
île raconte une scène assez terrible un
jour il est à megève il voit passer
chantal nobel qui a du mal à marcher
évidemment ils hésitent à aller lui
parler et c'est pas un manque de courage
derrière mais mais il va pas quoi parce
qu'il sait pas trop quoi lui dire mais
n'y a pas grand chose à dire moi donc
choses à dire et c'est navrant pour elle
parce que comme il dit de troncs
d'arbres n'aurait pas été là et
elle n'aurait pas été aussi gravement
blessé ouais et là effectivement sa
carrière en prend un coup il perd le
contact avec le avec le public un faux
pas il perd le contact avec le métier et
parce que nous avons reçu énormément de
lettres justement de son public qui ne
comprenaient pas ce qui se passait et je
pense pas que le contact avec le public
ait été coupé à ce moment là loin mais
ni lui ni moi n'avons encore compris
pourquoi ça a duré si longtemps ça
durait quand même temps moins disant
ouais
ça le torturer lui non pas du tout
torture est trop fort comme russell
ennuyait il se posait des questions
saltor tweedy qu'ils aient pensé tous
les jours mais il pensait le sale
torturait parvint justement parce que
c'est un musicien qui continuait à jouer
sa musique et que et que ça l'était
beaucoup
sacha distel disparu en juillet dernier
à l'âge de 71 ans il ne l'est pas
c'est incroyable variété mais j'en passe
qui il est mort jeune pour tout le monde
comme il est tellement beau et bien
concerné c'est incroyable quand tu dis
qu'ils avaient soi c'est des gens comme
ça jean piat est pareil l'économie de la
vieillesse notamment à d'autres la
machin qu'on a revu la semaine dernière
il a pris 15 ans la
com et s'appelle alors gérard darmon ah
oui
alors ses conquêtes d'un côté votre
fidélité de l'autre sacha distel a rendu
jaloux beaucoup d'hommes voulu trouviez
quoi vous les femmes à sacha distel
interview voulu trouviez quoi
[Musique]
alors est ce que est ce que sacha par
exemple se retenait de critiquer quand
vous ratiez un créneau par exemple il
pourrait pas tellement donner des leçons
de conduite non plus
aïe aïe aïe je ne ratais jamais un
créneau elle est ce que par exemple
c'est le genre de mec à séparer le blanc
des couleurs
non et reboucher le tube de dentifrice
oui
skis regarder du foot en buvant de la
bière
non pour savoir ce que ça nous aide nous
ce qu'il faut faire et va faire alors
regardez n'ont jamais n'est pas du genre
non ils essaient des mots doux sur le
frigo non
car par exemple quand on lui demande et
si on avait grossi disait toujours non
et
10 est toujours debout ouais tu vois
jennifer s qui sentait bon le sable
chaud
et oui certes l oder neisse à
est-ce qu'il offrait des perles de pluie
d'un pays où il ne pleut pas
c'est une phrase que j'adore est-ce que
sacha été fidèle entre deux infidélité
oui
est-ce qu'ils offraient des fleurs tous
les jours non non est-ce qu'ils étaient
trop durs est est ce qu'ils faisaient
l'amour comme un dieu
j'ai jamais fait l'amour avec un dieu un
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu